este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a das
link apuesto a que entre las cosas y
otras te pasas el día entre el ordenador
la tablet el móvil un sinfín de
dispositivos y seguro que también usas
cientos de webs y apps donde tienes que
rodearte verdad y no hace falta ser
einstein para saber que utilizar la
misma contraseña en todos estos sitios
no es la mejor forma de minimizar tu
vulnerabilidad en la red pues atentos
porque aquí es donde entra en juego das
lane
daschle os va ayudar a generar
contraseñas seguras y cada vez que una
web te pide introducir las lo hará por
ti automáticamente también te permite
guardar la información de pago de tus
tarjetas para tenerlo todo siempre a
mano rellenar has todo de forma rápida y
sencilla es súper cómodo das line
también te proporciona el monitoreo de
la web esto consiste en escanear la web
en busca de datos personales filtrados o
robados y das line das lint alertará al
instante en caso de que tus datos se
encuentren donde no deben quedar forma
que puedas tomar medidas rápidamente
súper útil y como dice el dicho mejor
prevenir que curar
a tu vida más sencilla y beatas link.com
barra visual polític s para usar das
line de forma totalmente gratuita en tu
primer dispositivo y si decides que
quieres irte a la versión premium usa
nuestro código visual polític s para
obtener un 10% de descuento y ahora
ahora vayamos con el vídeo de hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
amigos si hay algo que ponen los tiros
de los nervios al régimen norcoreano y
que es capaz de desquiciar al mismísimo
kim jong-un esos son precisamente las
sanciones internacionales y es que tal y
como seguramente se sospechase corea del
norte es uno de los países más
castigados por las sanciones
internacionales de todo el mundo tal vez
el que más lo que el régimen norcoreano
entiende como un bloqueo económico del
imperio norteamericano al sistema
socialista chuche es en realidad una
respuesta conjunta de la mayor parte de
países del mundo contra el programa
nuclear y de misiles balísticos de
pyongyang un programa al que el régimen
le ha dado durante las últimas décadas
la máxima prioridad y eso que
desarrollar desde cero la capacidad para
construir bombas nucleares y fabricar
misiles intercontinentales pues no es
precisamente algo que resulte
especialmente barato sobre todo si
tenemos en cuenta los paupérrimos
niveles de vida que sufren los
norcoreanos pero ya sabéis cómo funciona
esto las necesidades del régimen por
encima de cualquier otro factor
mientras hay de canciones patrióticas
para qué preocuparse
[Música]
se estima que el coste de estos
programas militares norcoreanos han
ascendido a entre 1.000 y 3.000 millones
de dólares en el caso del programa
nuclear ya más de mil millones al año en
el caso del programa balístico por
poneros un ejemplo con lo que cuesta el
lanzamiento de un solo misil
intercontinental junto a las
instalaciones de lanzamiento se podrían
comprar casi 3 millones de toneladas de
maíz y claro en un país en el que la
gente literalmente batalla contra la
desnutrición estas cifras son capaces de
poner los pelos de punta
el caso es que este es el motivo
principal por lo que tanto los eeuu
primero como el consejo de seguridad de
naciones unidas llevan años impulsando
sanciones económicas y comerciales
contra corea del norte para así tratar
de persuadir al régimen de abandonar
estos programas militares sin embargo
amigos la realidad es que al margen de
los enormes perjuicios económicos
causados por las sanciones durante los
últimos siete años al país comunista el
objetivo de evitar el avance de estos
programas no se ha cumplido y la
pregunta que podemos hacernos es por qué
no ha funcionado las sanciones como es
posible que corea del norte a pesar de
ser un país cercado atrasado y sometido
a todo tipo de sanciones haya logrado
convertirse en toda una potencia nuclear
pues amigos es tan sencillo de contestar
como complejo de explicar
[Música]
corea del norte cuenta con un elaborado
y complejo mecanismo para evadir las
sanciones que consiste en elementos tan
dispares como el robo a bancos a través
de ingeniería financiera ciberataques y
virus informáticos tráfico de metales
preciosos y comercio ilegal en aguas
internacionales entre otras formas y si
a todo esto le sumamos además el
paraguas de países como china y rúsia
que aunque reconocen y asumen las
sanciones no hacen mucho por hacerlas
cumplir así que lo que nos encontramos
es con que a pesar de todo el régimen
norcoreano ha logrado mantener abiertas
sus vías de ingresos a pesar de las
sanciones
[Música]
ojo hablamos del régimen propiamente no
del país hay las cosas ya si son
diferentes las estimaciones del banco
central de corea del sur claro estiman
que la economía norcoreana lleva al
menos tres años con contracciones
cercanas al 5% anual lo que supone la
peor recesión desde 1997 aunque claro
las cifras se basan en estimaciones
estudios del comercio y otros tipos de
análisis algo abstractos porque al fin y
al cabo el régimen no ofrece información
sobre cifras reales
ah
todo ello sin embargo forzó a corea del
norte a tomar medidas que se concretarán
el próximo mes de enero de 2021
kim jong-un admite de forma extraña un
fracaso económico corea del norte y
establecerá un plan quinquenal económico
en un congreso el año que viene según
cacn a unión un dice que el país
enfrentado a inesperados inevitables
retos sin embargo aun con todo la
realidad es que a pesar de el
coronavirus las sanciones económicas y
casi cualquier cosa que suceda los
programas nucleares y balísticos siguen
adelante en este vídeo os vamos a contar
algunas de las formas con las que
correrá el norte se salta olímpicamente
las sanciones tanto de eeuu como de la
onu y como la presión del imperio
norteamericano se ha quedado tan corta
que no ha surtido efecto alguno en sus
programas militares esto que vais a ver
es el mundo real más allá de la política
de los grandes despachos atentos
[Música]
por cierto un anuncio que os puede
interesar si tenéis peques cerca
nuestros amigos de value school han
lanzado un nuevo canal value teams con
dibujos animados para los más pequeños o
os lo dejo en la descripción por si
quieres echarle un vistazo publicarán
nuevos capítulos cada poco tiempo
[Música]
están fracasando las sanciones de eeuu
queridos amigos queridas amigas de
visual política antes de meternos de
lleno a analizar si las sanciones de
eeuu han fracasado o no hay un par de
cosas que tenemos que tener en cuenta la
primera es que a pesar de que corea del
norte ha detenido por el momento sus
pruebas nucleares sus instalaciones de
producción de bombas atómicas siguen
intactas
además ojo porque el hecho de que ya no
realicen pruebas no tiene por qué
significar ningún tipo de gesto
particular sino que quizás ya no
necesitan probar nada porque ya han
completado esta fase del programa la
segunda cosa que tenemos que saber es
que en plenas conversaciones con eeuu y
corea del sur sobre paz y
desnuclearización el régimen comunista
ha seguido lanzando misiles
[Música]
por ejemplo el 2 de marzo de 2020 corea
del norte lanzó dos misiles balísticos
de corto rango al mar del este por su
parte durante todo el 2019 lanzó 25
misiles e hizo 13 pruebas más en sus
instalaciones por tanto el programa
balístico norcoreano sigue funcionando a
pleno rendimiento a pesar de ello la
administración trump no ha condenado ni
ha hecho absolutamente nada para
castigar este tipo de comportamientos
que suponen una clara violación de las
resoluciones de la onu pero centrémonos
y vayamos a la cuestión clave en este
vídeo como puede corea del norte
financiar todos estos programas si el
país que es muy pobre está además
sometido a fortísimas sanciones
internacionales no es una pregunta menor
el país comunista no puede exportar ni
metales preciosos ni hierro ni carbón en
gas minerales ni productos agrícolas ni
pescado marisco ni productos textiles ni
tampoco puede importar maquinaria
vehículos crudo o petróleo refinado por
encima del límite fijado por la onu de
500 mil barriles anuales
en otras palabras las sanciones escapan
literalmente la capacidad de corea del
norte de vender lo poco que producen
carbón arenas minerales o textiles sin
embargo atentos a esta noticia
corea del norte aumenta las
exportaciones ilegales de carbón
sugieren imágenes de satélite exacto
como ya os hemos adelantado corea del
norte ha desarrollado un complicado
sistema de exportaciones e importaciones
en alta mar mediante transferencias de
barco a barco y una extensísima red de
empresas pantalla y testaferros
internacionales estas transferencias que
se producen en aguas internacionales o
incluso en aguas territoriales chinas
permiten la cuerda del norte e ingresar
más de mil millones de dólares cada año
para ello se suelen utilizar barcos con
banderas y registros que van cambiando
cada poco tiempo hablamos de países como
togo o tanzania sierra leona o incluso
panamá ya que estos países no registran
o tienen sistemas muy laxos de control
de sus flotas esto se debe sobre todo a
la prohibición de transferencias barco a
barco con buques de bandera norcoreana
la resolución 2.375 del consejo de
seguridad de las naciones unidas pero
ojo los ingresos de corea del norte no
se quedan sólo en el carbón
[Música]
por ejemplo el país exporta con total
impunidad
arenas minerales a empresas de china
también mediante transferencias de barco
a barco solo el año pasado vendieron que
se sepa al menos 22 millones de dólares
de estas arenas a empresas chinas estas
arenas se utilizan sobre todo para la
construcción y en 2019 el centro de
estudios avanzados de defensa detectó un
fuerte incremento de la actividad de
barcos extrayéndolas en la costa de la
bahía de jesús'
y no sólo eso sino que también se
detectaron más de 100 barcos con bandera
china navegando en los alrededores de la
explotación de arenas de heads o la
actividad en jeju demuestra una escala y
nivel de sofistificación como ningún
otro caso conocido de evasión de
sanciones en el mar por parte de corea
del norte aportando nuevas evidencias de
la evolución de las habilidades de la
república popular democrática de corea
para coordinar y ejecutar operaciones
complejas con facilitadores en el
extranjero reporte del c4 ads pero los
egresos norcoreanos al margen de las
sanciones no terminan aquí con el norte
tiene también todo un ejército de
trabajadores en el extranjero
especialmente en china que envían
divisas extranjeras de vuelta a cuerda
del norte a mediante todo un complejo
entramado financiero que incluye
paraísos fiscales y aunque la onu obligó
a que se repatriará a esos trabajadores
de vuelta con el norte lo cierto es que
una buena parte de los 100 mil que
habían 2017 siguen trabajando en china y
en el sudeste asiático y ojo que no
hablamos de una cuestión menor para que
sabéis mi idea del dineral
corea del norte solo con esta actividad
ese año en 2017 el régimen comunista
ingresó alrededor de 2000 millones de
dólares en forma de remesas e impuestos
artificialmente desorbitados ahora bien
como llega todo ese dinero a corea del
norte pues bien parte de la respuesta
podemos tenerla aquí en esta
investigación
eeuu procesos norcoreanos y acuse al
estatal banco de comercio exterior
norcoreano the matter sanciones la
investigación de este caso concluyó que
el banco de comercio exterior norcoreano
empleó al menos 250 empresas pantalla
para realizar pagos al gobierno por
valor de 2.500 millones de dólares de
hecho las transferencias procedían de
países tan dispares y de dudosa
transparencia como china rusia libia o
tailandia ahí es nada
y todavía todavía hay más cuerda del
norte cuenta con una enorme cadena
estatal de restaurantes y restaurantes
con alrededor de 125 sucursales
dispersas por el mundo a día de hoy se
desconoce cuántos de ellos siguen
abiertos aunque hay evidencias de que
son varias decenas pues bien esta cadena
se llama pyongyang y su estructura se
basa en una red de empresas que
colaboran con empresas locales mediante
joint ventures en los países donde
operan restaurantes que por cierto
también le sirven para lavar el dinero
de actividades ilegales opacas que
contabilizan dentro de los ingresos de
esos restaurantes y un apunte importante
todo esto que les estamos contando no es
algo del pasado o lejano ni nada por el
estilo es algo que a día de hoy sigue
ocurriendo fórmulas que se están
utilizando en la actualidad para
financiar los caprichos de kim jong-un
entre ellos su programa de misiles
balísticos
[Música]
mientras tanto el gobierno de los eeuu
que es el principal valedor e impulsor
de las sanciones contra el régimen de
pyongyang se ha quedado callado y de
brazos cruzados casi que parece que la
estrategia de la administración trump en
cora del norte ha pasado por dejar que
kim haga lo que le dé la gana tanto con
sus misiles como con el dinero que
maneja en el extranjero con
negociaciones así es fácil tener éxito
solo tienes que dar todo lo que te pidan
y luego decir que te ha salido con la
tuya en fin el caso amigos es que en
toda esta historia de evasión de
sanciones hay algunos episodios capaces
de dejaros estupefactos que pensáis y os
digo mejora del norte ha conseguido
exportar ilegalmente carbón a su
acérrimo enemigo a su vecino a corea del
sur y si os digo que un cargamento de
mercedes benz de lujo pasó por el puerto
surcoreano de busán con total impunidad
si si nos estamos tomando el pelo los
gerifaltes del régimen consiguen comprar
todo lo que quieren ni siquiera tienen
que depender de china corea del norte
juega literalmente al límite fijaos
[Música]
más cerca del peligro más lejos del daño
os lo acabamos de contar cuerda del
norte consiguió en 2019 exportar carbón
de forma ilegal a corea del sur todos y
cada uno de los controles aduaneros
fallaron y alrededor de 3 millones de
dólares en carbón norcoreano se colaron
por el puerto de poja el destinatario
enermax una empresa surcoreana que
compró el carbón a otra registrada en
hong kong y que fue transportado por el
mismo barco que llevó de europa acordado
el norte varios mercedes benz de lujo
[Música]
de hecho ese barco registrado como de
n-550 5 descargó el carbón en corea del
sur en el viaje de vuelta tras dejarlos
merced después en pekín en el país
comunista
si nos estamos hablando de unos mercedes
que compró el gobierno de corea del
norte para el mismísimo kim jong-un de
los modelos may back s 62 y maybach que
s 600 pullman guardamos el que está
blindado hasta las trancas cada uno
cuesta entre 500.000 y 1,6 millones de
dólares ya sabéis cuestión de
prioridades
i
estos coches de lujo viajaron a través
de seis países de rotterdam en países
bajos de donde salieron los coches a
delem en china en un barco medio saca
japón en otro barco distinto y luego a
busán en corea del sur en otro barco
diferente y de aquí en busán es donde
los coches fueron cambiados al famoso
barco de n-550 5 me gustan partido en
anayet acá en rusia para finalmente ya
en el mismo barco descargar en corea del
norte donde supuestamente se cargó el
carbón que fue a parar a manos de la
surcoreana enermax y el que acabó
descargando empujando
[Música]
menudo manera de viaje vamos me willy
fog' los mercedes de lujo que el propio
kim jong-un luz en sus cumbres con
mandatarios internacionales como el
mismísimo donald trump pasaron por
países aliados de eeuu como son
japón países bajos o corea del sur sin
que nadie se diera cuenta claro a ver es
como buscar una aguja en un pajar los
norcoreanos lo saben y se aprovechan de
ello
para colmo las tensas relaciones del
gobierno norteamericano con rusia y
sobre todo con china con quienes todavía
hoy mantienen una guerra comercial
abierta han alejado a estos países de
colaborar para castigar a enemigos
históricos de eeuu como cora del norte
de hecho en los últimos dos años china
ha relajado sustancialmente la presión
que llevaba ejerciendo contra cobrar el
norte para evitar importaciones de
productos sancionados
hablamos de una falta de colaboración
que ha llegado hasta el punto de que
enormes buques de carga y graneleros
norcoreanos hayan sido vistos en aguas
chinas junto a tussam en una de las
zonas más patrulladas y militarizadas de
la costa china
una zona donde china tiene bases navales
con fragatas destructores buques de
vigilancia electrónica e incluso radares
de todo tipo vamos resulta imposible
pensar que el gobierno chino no
estuviera al tanto de estos movimientos
con lo cual la pregunta que deberíamos
hacernos es ha servido la política
exterior de donald trump y las sanciones
internacionales para acabar con el
programa nuclear y de misiles balísticos
de corea del norte pues bien la
respuesta es rotundamente no
[Música]
es más las sanciones son a día de hoy
más porosas que nunca y mientras
pyongyang voy a saltarse las con tanta
impunidad dijo con tantos apoyos la
política de negociar la renuncia a las
armas nucleares a cambio de levantar las
sanciones pues como que no tiene mucho
sentido o con otras palabras para que va
a kim jong-un a abandonar cualquiera de
sus dos programas militares estrellas
que lo que le dan a cambio es aliviar
unas sanciones que se salta cuando y
como quiere al menos en lo que al
régimen respecta y luego ya el pueblo
pasa hambre eso ya es cosa del
infortunio y del malvado imperio
norteamericano
en fin veremos a ver cómo se desarrollan
los acontecimientos pero lo cierto es
que corea del norte es hoy mucho más
fuerte militarmente que hace cuatro años
y esa es una realidad que en buena
medida tiene mucho que ver con la
política exterior de trump en la casa
blanca pero ahora turno para ti crees
que el camino es ahondar aún más en las
sanciones contra corea del norte existe
alguna diplomacia alternativa para el
bloqueo económico para debilitar al
régimen norcoreano déjanos vuestra
opinión aquí abajo en los comentarios y
como siempre si os ha resultado
interesante este vídeo no olvidéis darle
al botón de like suscribiros abisal
político muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]